c'est un budget pour la guerre sur wii
ou
espagnols étaient roms des terres casper
les crypto monnaie font partie
intégrante de la stratégie militaire
ukrainienne grâce à elle des milliers
d'équipements de combat sont achetés et
envoyé aux soldats sur le front cette
utilisation d'une ampleur inédite permet
à l'ukraine d'être en possession de
fonds disponibles quasi instantanément
alors les crypto monnaie est elle
l'ukraine a gagné la guerre sont-elles
des armes efficaces
réponse dans facture
dès le 26 février seulement deux jours
après le lancement de l'opération
militaire spécial russe le gouvernement
ukrainien et l'organisation ukraine d ao
diffuse des portefeuilles de crypto
monnaie leur permettant de recevoir
directement des devises numérique cette
stratégie d'un nouveau genre s'explique
d'abord par le positionnement ukrainien
sur les crypto monnaie selon le cabinet
jane analysis l'ukraine se classe 4e
dans le monde en termes d'adoption de la
cryptographie le président je pense qui
est assez ouvert avait rapidement
compris qu'il y avait en fait une une
opportunité à saisir et il a donc
mobilisé tandis qu'il savait qu'il ya
une appétence
de ces de six habitants pour la crypte
monnaie il en a profité pour
effectivement redoubler d'efforts et
donc vous offrir un cadre légal
l'ukraine et son président volodymyr
zelensky était déjà en faveur d'une
légalisation des crypto monnaie avant le
début du conflit un positionnement qui
s'est concrétisée par l'adoption d'une
loi en ce sens par le parlement
ukrainien le 17 février 2022 entériné mi
mars mais reste une solution rapide
économique et pratique recevoir des
fonds
ça permet également
limité avec une population des moments
divers
j depuis son smartphone envoyée
disons qu'on l'appelle en 8e kohn est un
appel à la séduction à la modernité un
appel qui a déjà permis aux deux
plateformes principales ukrainienne de
recevoir des dons d'une valeur de 100
millions de dollars en crypto monnaie ou
équivalent jeudi équivalent car dnf t
ont également été envoyés à l'ukraine
sous forme de dons comme ceux crypto
punk d'une valeur de 200 mille dollars
les gens ont compris qu'en fait dans un
monde où on paie en devises en fait on
met ça met un peu de temps à arriver là
le temps entre le moment où donne
l'ordre et où on fait la somme d'argent
arrive sur le compte finalement il se
passe plusieurs jours et bien
effectivement crypte monnaie en fait
c'est ça se sait se calculant minutes
donc bien évidemment c'est imbattable et
cette rapidité d'exécution a permis à
l'ukraine de soutenir son armée grâce au
cryptage monnaie dès le 5 mars soit
seulement une semaine après la
publication des clés publiques de
portefeuille de crypto monnaie le time
magazine affirmé que le gouvernement
ukrainien avait déjà dépensé 15 millions
de dollars des dons qu'il avait reçu en
cryptant monnaie le ministère de la
transformation numérique du pays a
réussi à trouver des fournisseurs en
europe et aux états unis pour tout le
matériel militaire dont il avait besoin
40% d'entre eux étant prêt à accepter le
paiement en devises numérique lorsque li
paiement sont possibles en cryptant
monnaie ballard une fois qu'en fait la
drees a reçu le paiement en crypto sur
une plateforme craignaient les
réutiliser pour pour payer en fait
les achats réalisés en crypto dans le
cas où le paiement en crypto monnaie
n'est pas réalisable la nouvelle
législation ukrainienne en la matière
permet là aussi de gagner en efficacité
grâce au cadre légal on a ce relais fait
par la banque centrale et les banques et
donc on passe par le fameux système
swift pour que tout ça aille jusqu'au
bout ce fameux système swift et
l'infrastructure de messagerie
financière internationale la plus
utilisée par les établissements
bancaires dans le monde le processus de
paiement en crypto monnaie comme en
devises est ainsi intégralement
maîtriser blond 11 mars à l'export
yaakov vice-ministre ukrainien de la
transformation digitale annoncé avoir pu
acheter grâce aux cryptes monnaies 5550
gilet pare balles quelques 3000 lunettes
à vision thermique ou encore 410 mille
rations alimentaires c'est quelque chose
qu'on a on a déjà vu mais il ya cette
échelle vives de la part
d'acteurs étatiques le german
[Musique]
recours au don occupe de monnaie ont
déjà été
utilisés notamment par le pape prône la
lutte armée
et si on estime que le gouvernement a
déjà dépensé environ 35 millions de
dollars en crypto monnaie depuis le
début de la guerre il pourrait avec les
quelque 65 millions encore à sa
disposition début avril acheté par
exemple 6 millions cinq cent mille
rations alimentaires de plus à 10 euros
l'unité comparé à l'aide internationale
l'apport en crypto monnaie même s'il est
inédit il est assez marginal côté
américains républicains et démocrates se
sont mis d'accord pour accorder une aide
exceptionnelle à l'ukraine d'un montant
de 14 milliards de dollars des millions
contre des milliards déjà voilà ça veut
dire que c'est des petits pourcentages
mais c'est des petits pourcentages qui
voit là contribuent positivement je
pense qu'à la fin des les colloques ou
d'organismes de ce type seront
importants anton fera le bilan que les
versements les soutiens qui sont faits
par le milton et qui sont bien cette
stratégie ukrainienne d'un nouveau genre
ouvre donc la voie de nouvelles
réflexions sur la crypto monnaie
toujours dans l'optique de récolter des
fonds grâce au numérique le pays a même
lancé mercredi 30 mars une collection du
nst consacré au début du conflit avec la
russie elle s'intitule meta history
museum of war